Good morning, ladies and gentlemen.
My name is Art Benjamin,
and I am a "mathemagician."
What that means is, I combine
my loves of math and magic
to do something I call "mathemagics."
But before I get started, I have
a quick question for the audience.
By any chance, did anyone happen
to bring with them
this morning a calculator?
Seriously, if you have a calculator
with you, raise your hand.
Raise your hand. Did your hand go up?
Now bring it out, bring it out.
Anybody else?
I see, I see one way in the back.
You sir, that's three.
And anybody on this side here?
OK, over there on the aisle.
Would the four of you
please bring out your calculators,
then join me up on stage.
Let's give them a nice round of applause.
(Applause)
That's right.
Now, since I haven't had the chance
to work with these calculators,
I need to make sure
that they are all working properly.
Would somebody get us started by giving us
a two-digit number, please?
How about a two-digit number?
Audience: 22.
AB: 22. And another two-digit number, sir?
Audience: 47.
AB: Multiply 22 times 47,
make sure you get 1,034,
or the calculators are not working.
Do all of you get 1,034? 1,034?
Volunteer: No.
AB: 594. Let's give three of them
a nice round of applause there.
(Applause)
Would you like to try a more
standard calculator, just in case?
OK, great.
What I'm going to try and do then --
I notice it took some of you
a little bit of time to get your answer.
That's OK.
I'll give you a shortcut for multiplying
even faster on the calculator.
There is something called
the square of a number,
which most of you know is taking a number
and multiplying it by itself.
For instance, five squared would be?
Audience: 25.
AB: 25. The way we can
square on most calculators --
let me demonstrate with this one --
is by taking the number, such as five,
hitting "times" and then "equals,"
and on most calculators
that will give you the square.
On some of these ancient RPN calculators,
you've got an "x squared" button on it,
will allow you to do
the calculation even faster.
What I'm going to try and do
now is to square, in my head,
four two-digit numbers
faster than they can do
on their calculators,
even using the shortcut method.
What I'll use is the second row this time,
and I'll get four of you
to each yell out a two-digit number,
and if you would square the first number,
and if you would square the second,
the third and the fourth,
I will try and race you to the answer. OK?
So quickly, a two-digit number please.
Audience: 37.
Arthur Benjamin: 37 squared, OK.
Audience: 23.
AB: 23 squared, OK.
Audience: 59.
AB: 59 squared, OK, and finally?
Audience: 93.
AB: 93 squared.
Would you call out your answers, please?
Volunteer: 1369.
AB: 1369.
Volunteer: 529.
AB: 529.
Volunteer: 3481.
AB: 3481.
Volunteer: 8649.
AB: Thank you very much.
(Applause)
Let me try to take this one step further.
I'm going to try to square
some three-digit numbers this time.
I won't even write these down --
I'll just call them out
as they're called out to me.
Anyone I point to, call out
a three-digit number.
Anyone on our panel, verify the answer.
Just give some indication if it's right.
A three-digit number, sir, yes?
Audience: 987.
AB: 987 squared is 974,169.
(Laughter)
AB: Yes? Good.
Another three-digit --
(Applause)
-- another three-digit number, sir?
Audience: 457.
AB: 457 squared is 205,849.
205,849?
AB: Yes?
OK, another, another
three-digit number, sir?
Audience: 321.
AB: 321 is 103,041.
103,041.
Yes? One more three-digit number please.
Audience: Oh, 722.
AB: 722 is 500, that's a harder one.
Is that 513,284?
Volunteer: Yes.
AB: Yes? Oh, one more, one more
three-digit number please.
Audience: 162.
162 squared is 26,244.
Volunteer: Yes.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)
(Applause ends)
Let me try to take this one step further.
(Laughter)
I'm going to try to square
a four-digit number this time.
You can all take your time on this;
I will not beat you
to the answer on this one,
but I will try to get the answer right.
To make this a little bit more random,
let's take the fourth row this time,
let's say, one, two, three, four.
If each of you would call out
a single digit between zero and nine,
that will be the four-digit
number that I'll square.
Nine.
Seven.
Five.
Eight.
9,758, this will take me a little bit
of time, so bear with me.
95 million --
(Sighs)
218,564?
Volunteer: Yes!
AB: Thank you very much.
(Applause)
(Applause ends)
Now, I would attempt to square
a five-digit number --
and I can --
but unfortunately,
most calculators cannot.
(Laughter)
Eight-digit capacity --
don't you hate that?
So, since we've reached
the limits of our calculators --
what's that?
Does yours go higher?
Volunteer: I don't know.
AB: Oh, yours does?
Volunteer: I can probably do it.
AB: I'll talk to you later.
In the meanwhile, let me conclude
the first part of my show by doing
something a little trickier.
Let's take the largest number
on the board here, 8649.
Would you each enter
that on your calculator?
And instead of squaring it this time,
I want you to take
that number and multiply it
by any three-digit number that you want,
but don't tell me
what you're multiplying by --
just multiply it by any random
three-digit number.
So you should have as an answer either
a six-digit or probably
a seven-digit number.
How many digits do you have, six or seven?
Seven, and yours?
Seven? Seven?
And, uncertain.
Seven.
Is there any possible way
that I could know
what seven-digit numbers you have?
Say "No."
(Laughter)
Good, then I shall attempt
the impossible --
or at least the improbable.
What I'd like each of you
to do is to call out for me
any six of your seven digits,
any six of them,
in any order you'd like.
(Laughter)
One digit at a time,
I shall try and determine
the digit you've left out.
Starting with your seven-digit number,
call out any six of them please.
Volunteer: 1, 9, 7, 0, 4, 2.
AB: Did you leave out the number 6?
Good, OK, that's one.
You have a seven-digit number,
call out any six of them please.
Volunteer: 4, 4, 8, 7, 5.
I think I only heard five numbers.
I -- wait -- 44875 --
did you leave out the number 6?
Same as she did, OK.
You've got a seven-digit number --
call out any six of them loud and clear.
Volunteer: 0, 7, 9, 0, 4, 4.
I think you left out the number 3?
AB: That's three.
The odds of me getting
all four of these right by random guessing
would be one in 10,000:
10 to the fourth power.
OK, any six of them.
(Laughter)
Really scramble them up this time, please.
Volunteer: 2, 6, 3, 9, 7, 2.
Did you leave out the number 7?
And let's give all four of these people
a nice round of applause.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)
(Applause ends)
For my next number --
(Laughter)
while I mentally recharge my batteries,
I have one more question for the audience.
By any chance, does anybody
here happen to know
the day of the week
that they were born on?
If you think you know
your birth day, raise your hand.
Let's see, starting with --
let's start with a gentleman first.
What year was it, first of all?
That's why I pick a gentleman first.
Audience: 1953.
1953, and the month?
November what?
23rd -- was that a Monday?
Audience: Yes.
Good. Somebody else?
I haven't seen any women's hands up.
OK, how about you, what year?
1949, and the month?
October what?
Fifth -- was that a Wednesday?
Yes! I'll go way to the back
right now, how about you?
Yell it out, what year?
Audience: 1959.
1959, OK -- and the month?
Audience: February.
February what?
Sixth -- was that a Friday?
Audience: Yes.
Good, how about the person behind her?
Call out, what year was it?
Audience: 1947.
AB: 1947, and the month?
Audience: May.
AB: May what?
Seventh -- would that be a Wednesday?
Audience: Yes.
AB: Thank you very much.
(Applause)
Anybody here who'd like to know
the day of the week they were born?
We can do it that way.
Of course, I could just make up
an answer and you wouldn't know,
so I come prepared for that.
I brought with me a book of calendars.
It goes as far back into the past as 1800,
because you never know.
(Laughter)
I didn't mean to look at you, sir --
you were just sitting there.
(Laughter)
Anyway, Chris, you can help me
out here, if you wouldn't mind.
This is a book of calendars.
Who wanted to know their birth day?
What year was it, first of all?
Audience: 1966.
66 -- turn to the calendar with 1966.
And what month?
Audience: April.
AB: April what?
Audience: 17th.
I believe that was a Sunday.
Can you confirm, Chris?
Chris Anderson: Yes.
AB: I'll tell you what, Chris:
as long as you have
that book in front of you,
do me a favor, turn to a year
outside of the 1900s,
either into the 1800s
or way into the 2000s --
that'll be a much greater
challenge for me.
AB: What year would you like?
CA: 1824.
AB: 1824, OK.
AB: And what month?
CA: June.
AB: June what?
CA: Sixth.
AB: Was that a Sunday?
CA: It was.
AB: And it was cloudy.
(Laughter)
Good, thank you very much.
(Applause)
(Applause ends)
But I'd like to wrap things up now
by alluding to something
from earlier in the presentation.
There was a gentleman up here
who had a 10-digit calculator.
Where is he, would you stand up,
10-digit guy?
OK, stand up for me just for a second,
so I can see where you are.
You have a 10-digit calculator,
sir, as well?
OK, what I'm going to try
and do, is to square in my head
a five-digit number requiring
a 10-digit calculator.
But to make my job more interesting
for you, as well as for me,
I'm going to do this problem
thinking out loud.
So you can actually, honestly hear
what's going on in my mind
while I do a calculation of this size.
Now, I have to apologize
to our magician friend Lennart Green.
I know as a magician we're not supposed
to reveal our secrets,
but I'm not too afraid
that people are going to start
doing my show next week, so --
I think we're OK.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
So, let's see,
let's take a different row of people,
starting with you.
I'll get five digits:
one, two, three, four.
Oh, I did this row already.
Let's do the row before you,
starting with you:
one, two, three, four, five.
Call out a single digit --
that will be the five-digit number
that I will try to square, go ahead.
Five.
Seven.
Six.
Eight.
Three.
57,683 --
squared.
Yuck.
Let me explain to you
how I'm going to attempt this problem.
I'm going to break the problem
down into three parts.
I'll do 57,000 squared,
plus 683 squared,
plus 57,000 times 683 times two.
Add all those numbers together,
and with any luck, arrive at the answer.
Now, let me recap.
(Laughter)
Thank you.
While I explain something else --
(Laughter)
-- I know, that you can use, right?
While I do these calculations,
you might hear certain words,
as opposed to numbers,
creep into the calculation.
Let me explain what that is.
This is a phonetic code,
a mnemonic device that I use,
that allows me to convert
numbers into words.
I store them as words, and later on
retrieve them as numbers.
I know it sounds complicated; it's not.
I don't want you to think you're seeing
something out of "Rain Man."
(Laughter)
There's definitely
a method to my madness --
definitely, definitely.
Sorry.
(Laughter)
If you want to talk to me
about ADHD afterwards,
you can talk to me then.
By the way, one last instruction,
for my judges with the calculators --
you know who you are --
there is at least a 50 percent chance
that I will make a mistake here.
If I do, don't tell me
what the mistake is;
just say, "you're close,"
or something like that,
and I'll try and figure out the answer --
which could be pretty
entertaining in itself.
If, however, I am right,
whatever you do,
don't keep it to yourself, OK?
(Laughter)
Make sure everybody knows
that I got the answer right,
because this is my big finish, OK.
So, without any more stalling,
here we go.
I'll start the problem
in the middle, with 57 times 683.
57 times 68 is 3,400, plus 476 is 3876,
that's 38,760 plus 171,
38,760 plus 171 is 38,931.
38,931; double that to get 77,862.
77,862 becomes cookie fission,
cookie fission is 77,822.
That seems right, I'll go on.
Cookie fission, OK.
Next, I do 57 squared,
which is 3,249, so I can say,
three billion.
Take the 249, add that to cookie, 249,
oops, but I see a carry coming --
249 --
add that to cookie, 250 plus 77,
is 327 million --
fission, fission, OK,
finally, we do 683 squared,
that's 700 times 666, plus 17 squared
is 466,489, rev up if I need it,
rev up, take the 466,
add that to fission, to get,
oh gee --
328,489.
Audience: Yeah!
AB: Good.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)
I hope you enjoyed mathemagics.
Thank you.
(Applause)